Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, episode 41, Node.js. Take it away, Patrick. So recently, the FCC came out with their long-awaited net neutrality ruling, and they've tried several times to effectively get net neutrality to be able to be enforced and gotten, I think, this is such a complicated topic.
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 41 期，Node.js。Patrick，开始吧。最近，FCC 发布了他们期待已久的“网络中立”裁决，他们曾多次尝试有效地强制执行网络中立，我认为这是一个非常复杂的话题。
I feel like you need to be a lawyer to really understand it, or maybe just someone who knows more lawyeries than me. So the way I understand it is they tried several times to be able to basically enforce net neutrality and got told by the courts they couldn't do it that way. And so their most recent attempt was to do it by saying that broadband is essentially a utility and that therefore the SEC has the right to be able to regulate it. But of course, this is interesting because some people are opposing the fact that the FCC is even getting involved at all.
我觉得你得是个律师才能真正理解它，或者至少得是个比我更懂法律的人。据我理解，他们曾多次尝试强制执行网络中立，但被法院告知不能那样做。所以他们最近的尝试是宣布宽带本质上是一种公用事业，因此 FCC 有权对其进行监管。但这很有趣，因为有些人反对 FCC 介入此事。
So people in the tech industry generally support the idea that net neutrality is a good thing, but that it may be bad to have the government somehow having to defend the rights of the internet in that way, may just be asking for trouble, that they'll start putting their hands into other things on the internet. And of course, other people are complaining because of what they had to do by saying that broadband was a utility. Some people are complaining that's you know not well i guess it's a that becomes a political right wing versus left wing complaint about that that's anti-company or uh yeah so some such problem i'm going to try to explain net neutrality and then you can correct me so i think so net neutrality means so a neutral
科技行业的人通常支持网络中立是件好事，但政府以这种方式捍卫互联网权利可能不是好事，这可能会自找麻烦，因为他们会开始插手互联网上的其他事情。当然，其他人也在抱怨，因为他们不得不将宽带定义为公用事业。有些人抱怨说，这变成了政治上的左右派之争，说这是反公司行为，或者诸如此类的问题。我要试着解释一下网络中立，然后你可以纠正我。我认为网络中立意味着……一个中立的
internet is one where so okay okay, just step back. So the way the internet works, right? You say, I want to go to yahoo.com. And what happens is your machine, so there's a bunch of machines that resolve Yahoo.com to an IP address. So those are called domain name service machines. So you contact one of these domain name service machines. There's typically one for your ISP. And you say, okay, what is the address for Yahoo.com?
互联网是指……好吧，退一步说。互联网的工作方式是这样的，对吧？你说，我想去 yahoo.com。发生的事情是你的机器……有一堆机器将 Yahoo.com 解析为 IP 地址。这些被称为域名服务机器。所以你联系其中一台域名服务机器。通常你的 ISP 会有一台。你说，好吧，Yahoo.com 的地址是什么？
And they give you a number. And then you start sending packets to that number and each machine along the way kind of knows where that packet needs to go and also knows what machines it's connected to and tries to get the packet a little bit closer to its destination and so there's all of these hops where you're bouncing from one machine to the other until finally you reach Yahoo.com, one of their front-end machines. And then they fill that packet. They create their own packet, which has the Yahoo.com site on it, like a bunch of packets which have that site on it. And then they send those packets back to you.
他们给你一个数字。然后你开始向那个数字发送数据包，沿途的每台机器都知道数据包需要去哪里，也知道它连接了哪些机器，并试图让数据包离目的地更近一点。所以有所有这些跳转，你从一台机器跳到另一台机器，直到最后你到达 Yahoo.com 的前端机器之一。然后他们填充那个数据包。他们创建自己的数据包，上面有 Yahoo.com 网站，就像一堆带有该网站的数据包。然后他们把这些数据包发回给你。
But along the way it bounces through all these machines and a neutral internet is one where all those machines along the way including your isp just forward the packets without any discrimination so not like a net like if we didn't have net neutrality then what they could do is they could say oh you know here's a packet containing netflix movie like a piece of a netflix movie so i'm going to charge patrick you know that a fraction of a cent for this packet but then if the packet doesn't have a netflix movie if it has something else maybe it's free um did i does that kind of explain it or yeah i mean this is where it begins that i the mishmash of not understanding the
但在沿途，它会经过所有这些机器。中立的互联网是指沿途的所有机器，包括你的 ISP，都只是转发数据包而不进行任何歧视。如果我们没有网络中立，他们可以这样做：他们可以说，哦，这是一个包含 Netflix 电影的数据包，所以我打算向 Patrick 收取几分钱。但如果数据包里没有 Netflix 电影，而是其他东西，也许是免费的。我这样解释对吗？或者说，这就是混乱的开始，我不理解其中的
politics of it and then the uh you know the peering arrangements is another thing that comes into play here that uh certain website certain computers send a lot of traffic and others receive it or source it or sync it, I guess, is the equivalent. Google doesn't generate a lot of traffic, but it receives a lot of traffic. Wait, really? Isn't it the other way around? Well, who's requesting it? Google.com doesn't ask for a lot of traffic. Like it doesn't cause traffic to be generated.
政治因素，还有对等安排是另一个发挥作用的事情。某些网站、某些计算机发送大量流量，而其他网站接收或作为源头或汇点。谷歌不产生大量流量，但它接收大量流量。等等，真的吗？不是反过来吗？谁在请求它？Google.com 不会请求大量流量。它不会导致流量产生。
It's sending lots of packets in reply. Like you go to YouTube, right? So if I go to YouTube, I send a small amount of packets, but I'm the one that is initiating. YouTube isn't sending me stuff without me asking. Oh, I see. I send YouTube stuff without it asking. Gotcha.
它在回复中发送大量数据包。比如你去 YouTube，对吧？如果我去 YouTube，我发送少量数据包，但我才是发起者。YouTube 不会在我没要求的情况下给我发东西。哦，我明白了。我给 YouTube 发东西，它没要求。明白了。
So you ask youtube for information and then they just like fill you full of information so yeah i send a small amount of data and they send a large amount of data back but it matters because the you know who like essentially they're acting in response to a request from me got it got it so there's something there too and like so my isp has to uh you, bring in a lot of data and doesn't send out much data. Right. But the data it does send out is the cause for all the data that's coming back. Right.
所以你向 YouTube 请求信息，然后他们就像给你塞满了信息。所以我发送少量数据，他们发回大量数据。但这很重要，因为……本质上他们是在响应我的请求。明白了。所以这里也有一些东西。我的 ISP 必须引入大量数据，而不发送多少数据。对。但它发送的数据是导致所有数据回流的原因。对。
That makes sense. Yeah. So, I mean, you have to do a search to get a result or you have to, you know, click play on a video to start getting the video. So it's always your um the causal nature is always you but then the effect is that google or youtube or whoever just dumps a bunch of data on you um yeah so then the belief is that you know google slash youtube or facebook or insert any large website should pay because they don't, you know,
这说得通。所以，你必须进行搜索才能得到结果，或者你必须点击视频播放才能开始获取视频。所以因果关系总是你，但结果是谷歌或 YouTube 或其他任何人给你倾倒了一堆数据。所以人们认为谷歌/YouTube 或 Facebook 或任何大型网站应该付费，因为他们……
it's their, their traffic isn't symmetrical, right? Like it, because of this asymmetry that there's some, there's something there and they're not sharing their fair burden or something versus a ISP probably also has people who host servers there. And so they actually are sending out traffic as like they are doing both ways.
他们的流量不对称，对吧？因为这种不对称，他们没有分担公平的负担，而 ISP 可能也有人在那里托管服务器。所以他们实际上是在双向发送流量。
Yeah. So their traffic is more balanced. Yeah. I mean, there and so they actually are sending out traffic as like they are doing both ways yeah so their traffic is more balanced yeah i mean part of it is you know to argue to play devil's advocate i mean people who argue against net neutrality they say that basically you know there's some people who consume you know i think netflix consumes like a third of the internet or something like that during peak hours. And so Netflix has no incentive to be judicious and responsible with their bandwidth because it's basically free. I mean, they might pay their ISP to, you know, push out all of that traffic and have the infrastructure. But then all of those hops in between, they're just kind of freeloading in a sense. And so there's this idea that kind of the people who are using all of this traffic and requiring all this infrastructure should also be financially responsible for it and that was kind of the that's the anti
是的。所以他们的流量更平衡。为了唱反调，反对网络中立的人说，有些人消耗了……我认为 Netflix 在高峰时段消耗了互联网的三分之一左右。所以 Netflix 没有动力去审慎和负责地使用带宽，因为这基本上是免费的。他们可能会付钱给 ISP 来推送所有这些流量并拥有基础设施。但在中间的所有跳转中，他们某种程度上是在“白嫖”。所以人们认为，使用所有这些流量并需要所有这些基础设施的人也应该在经济上负责，这就是反
net neutrality argument the net neutrality argument is like this is very complicated and difficult to enforce and i mean if there's no i think the net net neutrality is slightly more subtle is that not that netflix should be more less responsible, but that it doesn't matter if you're Netflix, Facebook or a small startup that they should all pay the same rates. Right. That's right. Right. So so you may pay more. Netflix will pay a lot more than a tiny startup, but the amount they pay divided by the amount of traffic is the same. Yeah, yeah, you're right. You're right. Sorry, sorry. It's like a subtle nuance, but it matters. traffic is the same yeah yeah you're right you're right sorry sorry it's like a subtle nuance but it matters yeah that makes sense you're right because
网络中立的论点。网络中立的论点是，这非常复杂且难以执行。我认为网络中立稍微微妙一点，不是说 Netflix 应该少负责任，而是无论你是 Netflix、Facebook 还是小型初创公司，你们都应该支付相同的费率。对，没错。所以你可能付得更多。Netflix 会比小型初创公司付得多得多，但他们支付的金额除以流量是一样的。是的，你是对的。抱歉，这是一个微妙的细微差别，但很重要。
yeah you're right if if you it's like a toll road right like if you have more vehicles in your fleet going on that toll road you're naturally going to pay more um but uh but everyone gets charged but you can't say oh your truck is a walmart truck and and I don't like Walmart or Walmart, you know, trucks are worse for my business in some other way. And so I want to discriminate against Walmart trucks and make them pay twice as much. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Um, so yeah, we both kind of, I don't know about you, but I'm kind of foreign at neutrality.
是的，你是对的。这就像收费公路，对吧？如果你的车队在收费公路上有更多的车辆，你自然会付更多的钱。但每个人都被收费，你不能说，哦，你的卡车是沃尔玛的卡车，我不喜欢沃尔玛，或者沃尔玛卡车对我的生意有其他坏处。所以我想歧视沃尔玛卡车，让他们多付两倍的钱。是的，完全正确。所以，我们俩都……我不知道你怎么样，但我倾向于支持网络中立。
I never really understood the idea of charging different people, different amounts, but amounts but uh i also haven't been keeping too up to date with it so yeah my opinion is hard because it's yes the idea is good i want the internet to be neutral but like how do you enforce it who enforces it yeah right this becomes where the problem where it gets sticky yeah that makes sense so um we have a correction from last episode episode 40 uh and this is by andy andy wrote into us to say that we've made a mistake no i was giving you time to recover from passing out first time ever i'm okay yes first time ever uh so we were we were ranting about pre-verse post increment and we weren't being very careful or i wasn't at least being very careful in how i was stating it
我从来没真正理解向不同的人收取不同金额的想法，但我也没有跟进最新的进展。所以我的观点很难说，因为想法是好的，我希望互联网是中立的，但你如何执行它？谁来执行？这正是问题变得棘手的地方。我们有一个来自上一期（第 40 期）的更正，这是 Andy 写信告诉我们我们犯了一个错误。不，我是在给你时间从昏厥中恢复过来。这是第一次。我没事。是的，第一次。我们当时在抱怨前置递增与后置递增，我们不够小心，或者至少我没有很小心地陈述它。
and saying that it kind of doesn't make a difference and how i prefer doing post increment in like a for loop for instance because that's the way i was taught um and it does actually matter a lot and especially in the case where you have like classes in c plus plus not basic native data types because doing the post increment requires a copy operator because it needs to invoke use the before value and the after value so it needs two copies of the object which does add overhead and so you have to be careful when you're using post increment that you really need it and that there is could potentially be a non-trivial cost to it yeah especially with with iterators yeah i mean if you're using it with an int the compiler will probably just optimize it
说它没什么区别，以及我为什么在 for 循环中更喜欢使用后置递增，因为那是我的教法。但它实际上确实很重要，特别是在 C++ 中有类而不是基本原生数据类型的情况下，因为执行后置递增需要一个复制运算符，因为它需要调用使用之前的值和之后的值，所以它需要对象的两个副本，这确实增加了开销。所以在使用后置递增时必须小心，你确实需要它，而且它可能存在非平凡的成本。是的，特别是对于迭代器。如果你在 int 上使用它，编译器可能会为你优化它。
for you but yeah that was my well integral type there we go that was the word i was i'm yeah primitive type or a primitive integral type right something that is kind of native like i don't i don't know that it makes a big difference but to be fair it's better to adopt a habit that's good for everything than try to remember the nuances yeah that makes sense makes sense so i stand corrected all right should have been more specific first time ever we can make a mistake once um news so this is total cop-out news but uh i'm really proud of this excited about it but uh i made a wiki a wiki engine um So basically, you know, there's Wikipedia. Sorry, they're not Wikipedia.
但那是我的……整数类型，就是这样，那是我想说的词。原始类型或原始整数类型，对吧？某种原生的东西。我不知道它是否有很大区别，但公平地说，养成对所有情况都好的习惯，比试图记住细微差别要好。这说得通。所以我收回前言。好吧，我应该更具体一点。第一次犯错，我们可以犯一次错。新闻……这是完全偷懒的新闻，但我对此感到非常自豪和兴奋，我制作了一个 Wiki 引擎。基本上，你知道有维基百科。抱歉，不是维基百科。
There's MediaWiki, which Wikipedia is based on. There's Twiki, and there's a couple others that kind of dominate the wiki engine market or space, mind share, if you will. And these are good, for like public environments um but they don't really they never really worked well for corporate environments um you'd always see people like try to have a meeting uh on wikipedia like try not wikipedia but try to have like uh like meeting notes in a wiki and then you then two people can't edit it at the same time. Most of them don't allow that collaborative editing.
有 MediaWiki，维基百科就是基于它的。还有 Twiki，还有其他几个在 Wiki 引擎市场或领域占据主导地位的。这些对于公共环境来说很好，但它们在企业环境中从来没有真正发挥作用。你总是看到人们试图在 Wiki 上开会，试图在 Wiki 中记录会议纪要，然后两个人不能同时编辑它。大多数都不允许那种协作编辑。
Also it's too hard. If you see a typo in a wiki, like in your internal wiki, it's such a huge pain in the butt. You have to click edit, you have to go find the typo in the markup language, correct it, then click save, and each time it's like a page load, so it's maybe like five seconds. So it takes probably 30 seconds to fix a typo in a normal wiki. And so what ends up happening is as code is evolving and processes are changing quickly, people are just not keeping the wiki up to date.
而且太难了。如果你在 Wiki 中看到一个错别字，比如在你的内部 Wiki 中，那真是太痛苦了。你必须点击编辑，必须去标记语言中找到错别字，纠正它，然后点击保存，每次都要加载页面，所以可能需要五秒钟。所以在普通的 Wiki 中修复一个错别字可能需要 30 秒。所以发生的情况是，随着代码的演变和流程的快速变化，人们根本没有保持 Wiki 的更新。
So I created a wiki where it's very simple to update and it's collaborative so um it's uh node.js and uh javascript on the browser i'm talking about this i know spoiler and uh mongo db for the database so if you can get mongo db and node.js, you're good to go. And everyone on Twitch saw that Angry YOLO is following me on Twitch. Thank you, Angry YOLO for the follow. Anyway, so if you have all of that, not too bad. You can get it set up on Heroku or something pretty easily. And you can get this wiki I've been running. It's pretty cool. When you go into edit mode, it turns into like this Google Doc thing where like several people can edit at the same time.
所以我创建了一个 Wiki，它更新非常简单，而且是协作的。它是 Node.js 和浏览器端的 JavaScript。我在谈论这个，我知道剧透了，还有 MongoDB 作为数据库。所以如果你能搞定 MongoDB 和 Node.js，你就准备好了。Twitch 上的每个人都看到 Angry YOLO 在 Twitch 上关注我了。谢谢 Angry YOLO 的关注。总之，如果你有所有这些，还不错。你可以很容易地在 Heroku 之类的地方设置它。你可以得到我一直在运行的这个 Wiki。它很酷。当你进入编辑模式时，它会变成像 Google Doc 那样的东西，几个人可以同时编辑。
So if you have like a meeting, one person can project the wiki and everyone else could be editing the wiki and kind of filling things in or making corrections and it just kind of naturally works. And then it's also permanent, has a full text search and things like that. So I think it's pretty cool.
所以如果你开会，一个人可以投影 Wiki，其他人可以编辑 Wiki，填补内容或进行更正，它自然而然地就能工作。而且它是永久的，有全文搜索之类的功能。所以我认为它很酷。
Give it a shot. Let me know what you think. If you hate your wiki at your company or you haven't started one yet, try this one. And yeah, let me know how it goes. Very nice. I really want to run this and try this, but yeah, we have other things we use and so i'm not sure it'll go over that well at my company so i'll say i'll do it my spare time yeah you could always ping somebody and say uh you can run the demo i'll actually change the link this is we need
试一试。让我知道你的想法。如果你讨厌你公司的 Wiki，或者还没开始用，试试这个。让我知道进展如何。非常好。我真的很想运行并尝试这个，但我们有其他使用的东西，所以我不知道它在我公司会不会受欢迎，所以我会在业余时间做。你可以随时 ping 某人说，你可以运行演示。我实际上会更改链接，我们需要
to talk about software as a service you need to offer this as a service uh i could totally do that but i don't know. The thing is, is like most companies are kind of private about their data. Yeah. So, but yeah, check this out. It's a little demo and you can go and edit it. And I have no friends, so I wouldn't ever be able to see anyone editing it with me. All right.
谈谈软件即服务，你需要把它作为一种服务提供。我完全可以做到，但我不知道。问题是，大多数公司对他们的数据比较私密。所以，看看这个。这是一个小演示，你可以去编辑它。我没有朋友，所以我永远无法看到有人和我一起编辑。好吧。
I'm just being sad okay my link of the week or link of the week oh man my link to talk about is the 8cc small c compiler so i ran across this the other day in a news story and that was interesting because i'm constantly wanting to learn more about kind of compilers and compiler theory it's one of those things i think uh everyone i don't know maybe not everyone but i feel like many people in computer science or doing software engineering get interested in compilers at some level but everyone kind of just has this belief and to be honest i've never looked at the gcc code so i have no idea how complex it is but i've heard it's really complex and i just assume it must be really complex yeah same here so i but i've never to be fair i've never looked at it so
我只是在自嘲。好吧，我的本周链接是 8cc 小型 C 编译器。我前几天在新闻故事中偶然发现了这个，这很有趣，因为我一直想更多地了解编译器和编译器理论。我认为这是每个人……我不知道，也许不是每个人，但我感觉计算机科学或从事软件工程的许多人在某种程度上对编译器感兴趣。但每个人都有这种信念，老实说，我从未看过 GCC 代码，所以我不知道它有多复杂，但我听说它非常复杂，我只是假设它一定非常复杂。是的，我也是。所以我……公平地说，我从未看过它。
i don't know that's a bad assumption it's got to be just total nightmare though i've heard that i heard that but i i you know i've never looked so i can't say and then there's things like clang llvm which are you know part of uh their goal is to kind of clean that up right anyways leave all that aside 8cc is just a compiler for the c language trying to support all the modern c11 language features um but it also has a goal to be very readable and simple and small um so i don't think they're trying to be the most optimal one but they are trying to be uh complete like not implement a c subset but actually implement all of the c language um and so i was reading through a little bits of the code just to check out.
我不知道，这是一个糟糕的假设。它一定是一场噩梦，虽然我听说过。但我从未看过，所以我不能说。还有像 Clang LLVM 这样的东西，它们的目标是清理它，对吧？不管怎样，撇开这些不谈，8cc 只是一个 C 语言编译器，试图支持所有现代 C11 语言特性，但它的目标也是非常可读、简单和小巧。所以我不认为他们试图成为最优化的，但他们试图成为完整的，不是实现 C 的子集，而是实际实现整个 C 语言。所以我读了一些代码片段来看看。
And I have it on my infinite to-do list to go through this and kind of really read through a lot of it. But the parts I read through were like, oh, I know what this is doing. Wow, cool. But I need to kind of get more into the understanding how it's hooked up and how it flows. So here's something parsing an abstract syntax tree node.
我的无限待办事项列表中有去通读它并真正阅读其中的大部分内容。但我读过的部分是，哦，我知道这是在做什么。哇，酷。但我需要更多地了解它是如何连接的以及它是如何流动的。这是解析抽象语法树节点。
OK, I can follow kind of what it's doing. But an abstract syntax tree node okay i can follow kind of what it's doing but how is the tree built where does it go to you know those kind of stuff i didn't get into but if you're interested i would check it out um and they have some links to other projects that are similar that may be of use as well yeah this would be totally awesome i've always wanted to do uh things like uh i had this one crazy idea. Oh yeah, like if you could turn C code. There was this project GCC XML
好的，我可以跟上它在做什么。但抽象语法树节点……好的，我可以跟上它在做什么，但树是如何构建的？它去哪里了？诸如此类的事情我没有深入研究。但如果你感兴趣，我会去看看。他们还有一些类似项目的链接，可能也有用。是的，这太棒了。我一直想做一些事情，比如我有一个疯狂的想法。哦，是的，如果你能把 C 代码转换。有一个项目叫 GCC XML
that turned C into XML so that you could do crazy things like like kind of automatically delete all the comments and things like that. And yeah, this would be good to read just to see if you could do like kind of these front-end things or like you want to add that one feature to see
它把 C 转换成 XML，这样你就可以做疯狂的事情，比如自动删除所有注释之类的。是的，读这个会很好，看看你是否可以做这些前端的事情，或者你想给 C 添加那个功能
that no one will let you did no one ever seems to want to support yeah yeah cool man it's awesome all right my news is our link I guess is tote 50 totally free lessons in graphic design theory is Is this BuzzFeed? No. No. So I'm totally interested in graphic design. I've been doing a lot of drawing in my spare time. And I've been really interested in
似乎没人愿意支持。是的，酷。好吧，我的新闻或链接是 50 个完全免费的平面设计理论课程。这是 BuzzFeed 吗？不。不。我对平面设计非常感兴趣。我在业余时间做了很多绘画。我一直对
sort of like the psychology behind it. Like there's all these rules, you know, like the don't put something in the middle of the page. You know, the golden rule. It's like the two-thirds something in the middle of the page uh you know the golden rule it's like the two-thirds rule all these things but uh you know i wanted to see something like a little bit more formal that tries to like codify them or at least explain like the intuitions behind them and things like that and so uh yeah i've been going through a bunch of these and some
它背后的心理学很感兴趣。有很多规则，你知道，比如不要把东西放在页面中间。你知道，黄金法则。它是三分之二……页面中间的某样东西……你知道，黄金法则。它是三分之二规则，所有这些东西。但我想要看到一些更正式的东西，试图编纂它们，或者至少解释它们背后的直觉之类的。所以我一直在看其中的一堆，还有一些
other resources and uh try and do a lot of drawing and things like that. And this was one of the ones I found particularly useful. So if you're interested in that kind of stuff, if you're building a website, drawing a picture, any of that kind of stuff, this will help. It's a very broad kind of topic in graphic design. So check it out. I have comments about this, but I'm going to save them for later. Okay. Because I think we'll talk more about this topic soon really okay dude okay never mind all right yeah we'll just have to wait and see um my next link is uh open gl from zero to hero
其他资源，尝试做很多绘画之类的。这是我发现特别有用的一个。所以如果你对这类事情感兴趣，如果你在建网站、画画，任何这类事情，这都会有帮助。这是平面设计中一个非常广泛的话题。所以去看看吧。我对此有评论，但我会留到以后再说。好的。因为我认为我们很快会更多地讨论这个话题。真的吗？好的，伙计。没关系。好吧，我们只能拭目以待。我的下一个链接是 OpenGL 从零到英雄。
sounds like something i need to read um and this is are you doing open gl like is is that uh thing of yours now no oh okay you just want to read it because it's cool yeah i don't know it's game graphics i don't know always it's always interesting to me i do do graphic stuff sometimes i wonder how many people uh got into computer science to make video games i bet it's probably 50 i have very low desire to make a full-fledged video game but i have more like demo scene inclinations but i want to like make like demo of like some cool thing and just like you know just play around like toy programs but with graphics yeah that's the thing i don't want to make the content but i just want same as you i just want to make something that's kind of cool but yeah i don't want to spend the time like
听起来像是我需要读的东西。你在做 OpenGL 吗？那是你的东西吗？不。哦，好的。你只是想读它，因为它很酷。是的，我不知道，这是游戏图形。我不知道，它总是让我感兴趣。我有时确实做图形方面的事情。我想知道有多少人进入计算机科学是为了制作电子游戏。我敢打赌可能是 50%。我制作成熟电子游戏的欲望很低，但我更有演示场景的倾向，但我想要制作一些很酷的东西的演示，只是玩玩玩具程序，但用图形。是的，就是这样。我不想制作内容，我只想和你一样，我只想制作一些很酷的东西，但我不想花时间像
writing the story and all that stuff yeah that's for people who have more time than i have um or it's their job uh but this is a series of tutorials um that it looks like there's going to be more but even the parts they have now take you from the parts i always find really difficult like getting open gl set up or even installed in this case in like visual studio, even, um, which can sometimes be harrowing experience,
写故事之类的。那是给有比我更多时间的人准备的，或者是他们的工作。但这是一系列教程，看起来还会有更多，但即使是他们现在拥有的部分，也带你走过了我总是觉得非常困难的部分，比如在 Visual Studio 中设置或安装 OpenGL，这有时可能是一种痛苦的经历。
um, to how do you draw a triangle, you know, shading the triangle. And then it goes into a basic parts of a game engine and like, you know, shaders and scene managing and all these things and how they fit in. Uh,
到如何画一个三角形，你知道，给三角形着色。然后它进入游戏引擎的基本部分，比如着色器和场景管理以及所有这些东西，以及它们是如何组合在一起的。
and I didn't go through the whole tutorial, but the parts I clicked through, through seemed really interesting and on point. And so if you're interested in it, check it out. And like I said, it's probably most people because I think a lot of people have this thing in the back of their head that one day they're going to make some awesome video game or OpenGL 3D thing. Cool, man. Yeah, that's awesome.
我没有看完整个教程，但我点击的部分看起来非常有趣且切中要点。所以如果你感兴趣，去看看吧。就像我说的，这可能是大多数人，因为我认为很多人脑子里都有这个想法，有一天他们会制作一些很棒的电子游戏或 OpenGL 3D 东西。酷，伙计。是的，太棒了。
Yeah, now there's like a a ton of these well we talked about unity actually that's right yeah we did but uh but still like you know a lot of the if you want to do something kind of really out there and like the coolest you know one man video games or like you know indie video games are the ones that have some crazy kind of mechanic which is very hard to get right with one of these high level things like minecraft for example you can't write minecraft in unity you have to do something kind of low level right and so uh it's really important to know open gl and the fundamentals yeah for me it's more like to and it sounds i guess it's kind of weird maybe it's i
是的，现在有成吨的这些。我们实际上谈到了 Unity，没错。是的，我们谈到了。但仍然，如果你想做一些真正出格的事情，比如最酷的单人电子游戏或独立电子游戏，它们都有一些疯狂的机制，这在这些高级工具中很难实现，比如 Minecraft。你不能在 Unity 中编写 Minecraft，你必须做一些底层的东西。所以了解 OpenGL 和基础知识非常重要。对我来说，它更像是……听起来可能有点奇怪，也许是……
don't know what how you phrase that but uh the fact that, okay, you go to some tutorial, like how to make an Android app, but then they actually don't do any of the interesting parts. It's just like you take some framework and then you like edit some XML and then like, okay, you have a Android app with a button. Okay, but like, that's not what I wanted to learn. Like I wanted to do something, you know,
我不知道你怎么表达，但事实是，你去某个教程，比如如何制作 Android 应用程序，但他们实际上并没有做任何有趣的部分。就像你采用某个框架，然后编辑一些 XML，然后你就得到了一个带按钮的 Android 应用程序。好吧，但那不是我想学的。我想做一些事情，你知道，
like I want a framework to get me almost there, but then I can do the interesting parts. So like for me, you know, like I want a framework to get me almost there, but then I can do the interesting part. So like for me, you know, things like Unity, if you're going to actually try to make a game is really good. But if you're just trying to like play around, sometimes it hides what maybe the parts that are interesting to you. And in my case that, you know, that would be kind of the lower level stuff of, you know, actually rendering the graphics. Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. But maybe I'm a strange kind of weird person. yeah well yeah that's a given but given all of that the other stuff you said makes sense yes time for book of the show book of the show my book of the show
我想要一个框架让我几乎完成，然后我可以做有趣的部分。所以对我来说，你知道，像 Unity 这样的东西，如果你真的想尝试制作游戏，那真的很好。但如果你只是想玩玩，有时它会隐藏你可能感兴趣的部分。在我的情况下，那将是底层的东西，比如实际渲染图形。是的，这说得通。但也许我是一个奇怪的人。是的，那是肯定的。但考虑到所有这些，你说的其他事情说得通。是的，节目书的时间到了。我的节目书
is you can draw in 30 days the fun easy way to learn to draw in one month or less. So I have to confess I haven't read this yet, but I have ordered it. I love drawing, but I'm not great at it. I'm good at doing, like, I'm good at being kind of a perfectionist in the sense of, like, making sure, like, you know, like, spending a lot of time on it until it kind of looks good. But then like, I feel like the people who are really good at drawing are the ones who can like, they have a certain tolerance for quality.
是《30 天学会绘画：一个月或更短时间内学习绘画的有趣简便方法》。我必须承认我还没读过，但我已经订购了。我喜欢画画，但我画得不好。我擅长做那种完美主义者，确保花很多时间在上面，直到它看起来不错。但我感觉那些真正擅长画画的人是那些有一定质量容忍度的人。
And then within that tolerance, they can just generate a lot. Like for example, it's the same as writing code, right? Like the code that I write on a day-to-day basis like might not be the cleanest code ever i mean i'm sure if i spent more time i could write better like cleaner code but i can write a lot of it in a day like i have like sort of a well-oiled machine uh where i just like can kind of churn out a bunch of code um and so that's what a good artist can do a good artist might not be as perfect
然后在那个容忍度内，他们可以大量生成。比如，这和写代码是一样的，对吧？我每天写的代码可能不是最干净的代码。我的意思是，如果我花更多时间，我肯定能写出更好、更干净的代码，但我一天能写很多。我有一个运转良好的机器，我可以产出一堆代码。所以这就是一个好的艺术家能做的。一个好的艺术家可能不像他想要的或能做到的那样完美，
as he wants or as he can be but he can get 90% of the way there in one tenth of the time that it takes me to get to get there, to get done so yeah I'm trying to read through these books
但他可以在我完成所需时间的十分之一内完成 90%。所以是的，我正在尝试通读这些书，
especially the ones on doing things quickly and i'll let you guys know how this goes but uh um but yeah i'm looking forward to getting in taking a look through so i'm a little up on you i'm like seven days into this book uh really you actually have this book yes um so this was saying i was going to talk about this later and you just had this like blank sound and I was like okay what are the odds that we both have the same book so
特别是关于快速做事的那几本。我会让你们知道进展如何。但我很期待去看看。所以我比你稍微领先一点，我已经读了七天了。真的？你真的有这本书？是的。所以这就是我刚才说我要晚点谈论这个，你刚才发出了那种空白的声音，我就想，我们俩都有同一本书的几率是多少？
everything you're describing except for the fact that I can't draw even if I take a long time so I'm just terrible at it so I got the roundabout story is there's this thing called urban sketching I don't know if you ever checked this out. There's a website, Urban Sketchers, if you search it. And they have like a very particular art style, which is exactly describing is exactly described by the words you were using, where the idea of urban sketching is you're out in the world like you're sitting on a bench.
除了我即使花很长时间也画不出来之外，你描述的一切都是这样，所以我画得很烂。所以绕了一大圈，有一件事叫城市写生。我不知道你有没有看过。有一个网站叫 Urban Sketchers，如果你搜索一下。他们有一种非常独特的艺术风格，正是你刚才用的词所描述的。城市写生的想法是你走在世界上，比如你坐在长椅上。
You're in a Starbucks and you're drawing fast. You're drawing just something that you're seeing and you can't take forever you can't be a perfectionist you're not making a gallery piece you're making something very loose but I'm just something so the style I've learned is kind of call it the ink and wash style so you kind of like draw with a pen and then they'd use some splatterings of color from watercolor and this is kind of like a very specific style that they're they they tend to be very similar a lot of them and this is cool that this is like got me into i wanted to do this i didn't know why but
你在星巴克，你在快速画画。你只是在画你看到的东西，你不能花永远的时间，你不能成为完美主义者。你不是在制作画廊作品，你是在制作非常松散的东西。但我学到的风格叫墨水和水洗风格，所以你用钢笔画，然后他们会用一些水彩的颜色飞溅。这是一种非常具体的风格，它们往往非常相似。这很酷，这让我进入了……我想做这个，我不知道为什么，但
like that style just stuck with me and like this quick loose drawing yeah it's fun uh and so i got in a series of weird tangents uh so i now actually i i kind of gave up the drawing a little except then i've come back to it because uh actually got into watercolor painting and so now i've been doing watercolor painting for about uh two or three weeks now and uh um it's been really interesting and so i've learned to need to draw again because you need to draw to be able to paint so blah blah blah so i'm back and and working on drawing again and i hadn't painted since like elementary school so i don't know however many years that is, many years. And so I got stuff like just doing it.
那种风格一直吸引着我，这种快速、松散的绘画。是的，这很有趣。所以我陷入了一系列奇怪的切线。所以我现在实际上放弃了绘画，除了我又回到了它，因为我实际上开始接触水彩画了。所以我现在已经画了大约两三周的水彩画了。这非常有趣，所以我学会了需要再次画画，因为你需要画画才能画画。所以巴拉巴拉，所以我回来了，又在努力画画了。我从小学起就没画过画了，所以我不知道那是多少年了，很多年了。所以我得到了像只是做它这样的东西。
And it was actually like, wow, this is really like relaxing. I don't know what about so different than coding it is, but I was really, really been enjoying it. So like I never really thought to do watercolor. Like I have pencil crayons and then I have, you know, like drafting pencils. But like what made you think to do watercolor specifically the urban sketching stuff oh so these are all watercolor you're saying so the color you see there is almost universally watercolor yeah oh and then they add the they do pencil drawing on top of it no no well so there's two ways one is like you spill
这实际上就像，哇，这真的很放松。我不知道它和编码有什么不同，但我真的很享受它。我从来没想过要画水彩。我有彩色铅笔，还有绘图铅笔。但什么让你想到专门做水彩？城市写生之类的东西。哦，所以这些都是水彩，你是说？所以你在那里看到的颜色几乎普遍是水彩。哦，然后他们添加了……他们在上面做铅笔画吗？不，不。有两种方式，一种是你把
some color across the page and then you just draw something on top of it for like effect but then others are where you draw a sketch uh in pencil or pen and then you kind of just like loosely color parts of it in water oh i see got it and the reason watercolor there is because it dries much faster than like a lot of the other kind of paints and it's much more portable because you can have the dried pucks and a little you know cup of water and you can be able to paint yeah yeah oh that's awesome yeah so now i've been doing like a little bit of watercolor stuff uh i won't say i'm great but i'm doing better than i thought i would be able to i can paint things that you can recognize wow that's awesome and so that's made me happy so and there's turns out there's tons and tons of videos on youtube about how to do like any of this kind of stuff so and i find it easier than drawing with a pencil because i feel
一些颜色洒在页面上，然后你在上面画点东西作为效果。但另一种是你用铅笔或钢笔画草图，然后你只是松散地给部分涂上水。哦，我明白了。水彩的原因是它比其他很多颜料干得快得多，而且它更便携，因为你可以有干颜料块和一个小杯水，你就可以画画了。是的，太棒了。所以我现在一直在做一点水彩画。我不会说我很棒，但我做得比我想象的要好。我可以画出你能认出来的东西。哇，那太棒了。这让我很高兴。而且 YouTube 上有成吨成吨关于如何做这类事情的视频。我发现它比用铅笔画画更容易，因为我觉得
like by nature the painting and specifically watercolor is very loose in nature so you can paint precisely but it wants to kind of run all over the page and so it forces you to be more interpretive which is something that i don't do by nature oh i see yeah that's that's my like flaw too is like if if something doesn't look realistic like if it if it doesn't match and i like have to fix it and so certain things like which are kind of there's certain things that are just always kind of drawn comically like for example like the fur of a tiger, like the outside, like the border between a tiger and whatever is behind the tiger. Like to actually draw that correctly is just insanely hard. But, you know, so like to draw it the way that you would see it, like the iconic drawing of a tiger is like kind of more abstract.
本质上，绘画，特别是水彩，本质上是非常松散的。所以你可以精确地画，但它想在页面上到处跑，所以它迫使你更具解释性，这是我本质上不会做的事情。哦，我明白了。是的，这也是我的缺陷。如果东西看起来不真实，如果它不匹配，我就必须修复它。所以某些东西总是被画得很滑稽，例如老虎的毛，外面的边界，老虎和老虎背后的东西之间的边界。要真正正确地画出那个东西简直难得离谱。但是，你知道，所以要像你看到的那样画它，老虎的标志性画法是更抽象的。
And I think that's where I have the most trouble. Yeah, to your point earlier, I don't know if you guys check out, anyone, guys or gals listening, check out like this urban sketching. To me, what you were saying earlier about kind of psychological almost, how that you can recognize something to be a person
我认为这就是我最困难的地方。是的，回到你刚才的观点，我不知道你们是否看过，听众中的任何人，看看这个城市写生。对我来说，你刚才说的关于心理学的东西，你怎么能认出某人是人，
when it's almost just like a couple loop squiggles and like hashy lines and a little bit of paint and you'll be like oh right like here there's a picture i'm looking right now like a picture of a marching band and it's like i can tell this is like a marching band and like but like there's so little detail here it's kind of crazy that i'm able to tell that that's what this is and then i can actually tell this is almost looks like a saint patrick's day whatever like but i don't know why i'm able to tell that like yeah it's just mind-boggling so yeah yeah learn to draw yeah but i i did enjoy the book i kind of put it back down because i started doing the watercoloring stuff but uh yeah i was enjoying it so far so i'll recommend it cool but you have to stick with it it's practice people just think
当它几乎只是几个圈圈和杂乱的线条以及一点点颜料时，你会说，哦，对了，这里有一张我正在看的照片，一张行进乐队的照片，我可以看出这是一个行进乐队，但这里几乎没有细节，我能看出那是行进乐队真是太疯狂了。然后我实际上可以看出这看起来几乎像圣帕特里克节之类的。但我不知道为什么我能看出这一点。是的，这简直令人费解。所以，是的，学习绘画。但我确实喜欢这本书，我把它放下了，因为我开始做水彩画了，但我到目前为止很喜欢它，所以我推荐它。酷，但你必须坚持下去。这是练习，人们只是认为
like i'm gonna sit down and just draw but that't happen. Like it's just very hard for your, even if you know in your head what you want to draw, your hand won't be able to do it initially. Yeah. I see what you're saying. So it takes more practice than I, everybody just chalks it up to talent. I did too.
我会坐下来画画，但这不会发生。即使你脑子里知道你想画什么，你的手最初也做不到。是的，我明白你的意思。所以它需要的练习比我……每个人都把它归结为天赋。我也一样。
And so, yeah, my book is completely unrelated. It's a science fiction. Go surprise. Patrick's recommending a science fiction book. Wow. I didn't it's a science fiction go surprise patrick's recommending a science fiction book wow i didn't know you read science fiction i only talk about a science fiction book or fantasy every single episode this one is a book that was released last fall abyss beyond dreams this is uh peter f hamilton's newest entry in the commonwealth saga of which i believe there are five or six books now um and uh i guess
所以，是的，我的书完全不相关。它是科幻小说。去惊喜吧。Patrick 推荐了一本科幻小说。哇。我不知道你读科幻小说。我每一期只谈论一本科学小说或奇幻书。这是一本去年秋天出版的书，《深渊之梦》。这是 Peter F. Hamilton 在联邦传奇中的最新作品，我相信现在有五六本书了。而且……我想
this would be like the seventh uh and i really enjoy his style i was really hoping this book was gonna have uh so he writes about kind of crazy future science and it's i guess considered hard sci-fi and a lot about how humans modify themselves in the future. And there is a good amount of it in here, but not as much as I was hoping. But it's still a really good story. I really enjoyed it. So I would recommend that, Abyss Beyond Dreams or any of Peter F. Hamilton's Commonwealth Saga books.
这大概是第七本了，我真的很喜欢他的风格，我本来非常希望这本书能有……他写的是那种疯狂的未来科学，我想这应该被归类为硬科幻，其中有很多关于人类在未来如何改造自己的内容。这里面确实有不少这方面的内容，但没有我预期的那么多。不过这仍然是一个非常好的故事。我真的很喜欢。所以我推荐这本书，《深渊之梦》（Abyss Beyond Dreams）或者彼得·F·汉密尔顿（Peter F. Hamilton）的《联邦传奇》（Commonwealth Saga）系列中的任何一本。
I don't know that you really, there's two books and then a trilogy and now this one, which is set in between the previous. So I wouldn't read any in the sets out of order, but i think you can read any of the sets in either in any order cool that makes sense that was confusing anyways check it out it made sense so on our oh go ahead oh no i was gonna say on a related note of books terry pratchett just passed away like a week ago um yeah and so he had uh alzheimer's um and for for a while and so he was kind of fading but uh but yeah he passed away about a week ago and uh yeah the world will miss terry pratchett disc world series uh we've had at least
我不知道你是否真的……有两本书，然后是一个三部曲，现在这本是设定在前作之间的。所以我不会乱序阅读这些系列，但我认为你可以按任何顺序阅读这些系列。酷，这说得通，刚才那段有点让人困惑。总之，去看看吧，这很有道理。那么，关于我们的……哦，你请说。哦，不，我本来想说，顺便提一下，特里·普拉切特（Terry Pratchett）大约一周前去世了。嗯，是的，他患有阿尔茨海默症，有一段时间了，所以他一直在衰退，但……是的，他大约一周前去世了。是的，世界会怀念特里·普拉切特的《碟形世界》（Discworld）系列，我们至少已经有了
one i know or maybe two um books that's books of the show which are books he wrote among other stuff there was this pretty epic image that someone hand drew of him shaking hands with death I can't seem to find it though yes which is one of the characters in his Discworld series oh yeah that's right
一本，或者可能是两本……节目中提到的书，这些书是他写的，除此以外还有其他东西。有人手绘了一张非常史诗般的图片，画的是他和死神握手，但我好像找不到了。是的，那是他《碟形世界》系列中的角色之一。哦，是的，没错。
he's shaking hands with one of his most famous characters let me see if I can pull it up i think also his i believe this is i want to say his daughter uh when she tweeted that he died also made a reference to his death character oh really nice so um i was gonna say the secret to me being able to listen to this uh bis beyond dreams is another uh quite long science fiction book, as many of mine are, because I have quite a long commute. And the way I'm able to do that
他正在和他最著名的角色之一握手。让我看看能不能把它找出来。我想他的……我相信这是……我想说是他的女儿，她在推特上宣布他去世时，也提到了他的死神角色。哦，真的吗？太好了。所以，嗯，我本来想说，我能够听完这本《深渊之梦》的秘诀是，它是另一本相当长的科幻小说，就像我的许多书一样，因为我的通勤时间很长。而我能够做到这一点的方式
is by listening to audiobooks. And this week we have an announcement that we now have Audible as one of our sponsors of the show. That's right. So you can go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown. And they have an offer where you can get to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown. And they have an offer where you can get a free month, which is Audible Works.
就是通过听有声读物。本周我们有一个公告，我们现在有了 Audible 作为我们的节目赞助商之一。没错。所以你可以访问 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。他们有一个优惠活动，你可以获得一个月的免费试用，这就是 Audible 的运作方式。
You can either just buy the audio books kind of like for a flat fee, or you can pay a subscription per month. I believe it's $15. And then you're able to download one book a month, essentially. And they have plans that have more books a month. And then you can keep them even if you cancel your subscription. So what I do is I have a subscription for a little while, get a couple books built up, and then I cancel my subscription. And then when I make it through those books, I get it again
你可以直接以固定费用购买有声读物，也可以按月订阅。我相信是 15 美元。然后你基本上每个月可以下载一本书。他们也有每月包含更多书籍的计划。即使你取消订阅，你也可以保留这些书。所以我所做的是，我订阅一段时间，积攒几本书，然后取消订阅。等我听完这些书，我再重新订阅。
because the subscription works out to be cheaper than just buying them directly off of their thing. And they also run great sales. As long as you're disciplined to get a book every month, then you can just continue to build up a queue of books. Oh, and you get a credit, and a credit is good for a book. And the credits don't expire until you cancel. So you can let them build up and then use them all at once and then cancel.
因为订阅比直接购买要便宜。而且他们还会进行很棒的促销活动。只要你有纪律每个月买一本书，你就可以不断建立一个书单队列。哦，你会得到一个积分，一个积分可以换一本书。而且积分在取消订阅之前不会过期。所以你可以让它们积攒起来，然后一次性用掉，然后再取消。
Oh, cool, cool, cool. Yeah, yeah. So they're pretty good about that. I've actually been pleased. And then I'm able to listen to it for however long, you know, after I've canceled. And then while you have the subscription, they also run sales, which are even cheaper. Or they also run deals where if you buy the Kindle version of the book and the Audible version of the book, sometimes it's cheaper than just buying the Audible version of the book.
哦，酷，酷，酷。是的，是的。所以他们在这方面做得很好。我实际上一直很满意。而且即使在我取消订阅后，我也能听很长时间。在你订阅期间，他们还会进行促销，价格甚至更便宜。或者他们也会提供一些优惠，比如如果你购买了 Kindle 版本的书和 Audible 版本的书，有时比单独购买 Audible 版本还要便宜。
And so I do that sometimes so you can get a lot of good listening material slash reading material um for a pretty decent price i feel like it's a good deal and so i'm glad that we can uh now have them on our show yeah definitely so yeah if you uh if you use the link that we'll provide in the blog then uh then that helps us out so we appreciate it about the show and check it out and if if you're always saying, man, I really wish I had more time to read, uh, and you're in your car or in a long commute, you first, you can listen to this podcast and then you can listen.
所以我有时会这样做，这样你就能以相当不错的价格获得大量的听书/阅读材料。我觉得这很划算，所以我很高兴我们现在能在节目中拥有他们。是的，绝对的。所以，如果你使用我们在博客中提供的链接，那会对我们有帮助，所以我们很感激。关于节目，去看看吧。如果你总是说：“天哪，我真希望我有更多时间阅读”，而且你正在开车或在长途通勤中，你首先可以听这个播客，然后你就可以听……
That's right. Oh man. Are we, are we, uh, encouraging our competition? I listened to both podcasts and a fiction books so yeah yeah there's definitely enough time for that i do the same thing i listen to uh i listen well i listen to just podcasts but i have like a ton of podcast like five different podcasts only five of my community more than five much longer than yours okay fair enough um cool so to the tools of the show my tool of the show is jacoco which is a java code coverage library so what this means you integrate it into your test environment well specifically integrate into your build system so if you're using you know maven or ant or Gradle or any of these things you integrate jacoco into one of those and then whenever you run your tests this will actually tell you what lines of
没错。天哪。我们是在鼓励我们的竞争对手吗？我既听播客也听小说，所以是的，绝对有足够的时间做这两件事。我也做同样的事情，我听……我听，好吧，我只听播客，但我有很多播客，大概五个不同的播客。只有五个？我的通勤时间比你的长得多。好吧，有道理。嗯，酷。那么，进入节目工具环节。我的节目工具是 JaCoCo，这是一个 Java 代码覆盖率库。这意味着你把它集成到你的测试环境中，具体来说是集成到你的构建系统中。所以如果你使用 Maven、Ant 或 Gradle 之类的工具，你就可以把 JaCoCo 集成到其中一个里面。然后当你运行测试时，它实际上会告诉你哪些行
code are covered in your unit tests and which ones aren't and so it's pretty cool like it'll give you a high level overview, like 6% or 70% of your project is unit tested. Only 70%? 70% of the lines. Boo. Yeah. But then you can drill in and say,
代码在单元测试中被覆盖了，哪些没有。这很酷，它会给你一个高层次的概览，比如你的项目有 60% 或 70% 进行了单元测试。只有 70%？70% 的代码行。嘘。是的。但你可以深入查看并说，
oh, I totally missed this class. You can exclude some classes, like if it's just like a main loop or something like void main or whatever just in its own class you don't want to unit test it so it has a bunch of options like that um it's pretty slick um i've been using it for not too long just a week or so but uh but it's pretty cool and uh it really kind of helps you to reduce the entropy like like if there's some code that's not unit tested, maybe it doesn't need to be there, right?
哦，我完全漏掉了这个类。你可以排除一些类，比如如果它只是一个主循环或者像 void main 之类的东西，或者无论它在它自己的类中，你不想对它进行单元测试，所以它有很多这样的选项。它非常简洁。我使用它的时间还不长，也就一周左右，但它真的很酷。它确实有助于减少熵，比如如果有些代码没有进行单元测试，也许它就不需要存在，对吧？
And so it kind of can really help improve the code quality. What do you have as your code coverage target? I don't know yet. So I ran this. So basically what happened is we had this kind of i don't want to use the word sprint because that reminds me of agile and all that those things that i kind of hate but uh but we had just we had just sort of a rush where we had a deadline that we were rushing to meet and we were able to meet the deadline but i mean we were here at the 11th hour just banging out a ton of code.
所以它确实可以帮助提高代码质量。你的代码覆盖率目标是多少？我还没定。所以我运行了这个。基本上发生的情况是，我们有这种……我不想用“冲刺”（sprint）这个词，因为它让我想起敏捷开发和所有那些我有点讨厌的东西，但我们确实经历了一阵忙碌，有一个我们急于完成的截止日期。我们能够赶上截止日期，但我的意思是，我们在最后一刻还在疯狂地写代码。
And so the code coverage is really bad. Really, really bad. In fact, we hadn't even started writing unit tests until this week. So the code coverage was zero. Nice. So I have to, you know, I don't really have a set target, like a certain percent. It's more just like I want us to write unit tests until, until things look good. You know, until like, we're happy with it. And then I'll try to figure out, it's hard for me to have a target when I've never really done this before. No, that's fine. Just some, some teams have like a, you know,
所以代码覆盖率真的很差。非常非常差。事实上，直到本周我们才开始编写单元测试。所以代码覆盖率是零。不错。所以我必须……你知道，我并没有设定一个具体的目标，比如达到某个百分比。更多的是我希望我们编写单元测试，直到……直到看起来不错。你知道，直到我们对它感到满意。然后我会试着去想，当我以前从未真正做过这件事时，设定一个目标对我来说很难。不，没关系。只是有些团队有，你知道，
like 90% is the desired goal or 100%, which can be very difficult. Yeah, I mean, I'm assuming if your goal is 100%, then you're excluding like void main or whatever. I mean, you could test it, but at that point, you're just kind of wasting time, right? Yeah, I mean, but you could get to essentially 99.99999 percent yeah right and then that doesn't even get into talking about branch coverage yeah yeah that's right which is not just every line of code but each path so if there's multiple ways to get into a if statement you exercise all the permutations yep yeah that's much much harder yeah that's brutal man okay my tool of the show is relatively limited but i've been using a lot and thinking
比如 90% 是期望目标，或者 100%，这可能非常困难。是的，我的意思是，我假设如果你的目标是 100%，那么你是在排除像 void main 之类的东西。我的意思是，你可以测试它，但在那一点上，你只是在浪费时间，对吧？是的，我的意思是，但你可以达到 99.99999% 左右。是的，没错。而且这还没谈到分支覆盖率。是的，没错。这不仅仅是每一行代码，而是每一条路径。所以如果进入 if 语句有多种方式，你要执行所有的排列组合。是的，那要难得多。是的，那太残酷了，伙计。好吧，我的节目工具相对有限，但我一直在使用它并思考
about it anyways and that's think or swim so think or swim used to be a uh a stock platform that was its own uh investment company but now it's part of a brokerage called td ameritrade and it's one of the options for interfacing with it and so i have some stock investments uh with td ameritrade and i've been using thinkorswim um but i really want to just use an opportunity first of all say i actually do like the interface and i almost exclusively do it from the phone so i don't do do tons of like really stock trading. It's more just investing. But I do it like exclusively from my phone and my tablet.
它。总之，那就是 ThinkOrSwim。ThinkOrSwim 曾经是一个股票平台，它是一家独立的投资公司，但现在它是 TD Ameritrade 经纪公司的一部分，它是与之交互的选项之一。所以我有一些股票投资在 TD Ameritrade，我一直在使用 ThinkOrSwim。但我真的想借此机会首先说，我确实喜欢这个界面，而且我几乎完全是在手机上操作的。所以我不会进行大量的股票交易。这更多是投资。但我几乎完全是在手机和平板电脑上操作。
I don't go on the website except to create the account. Like I manage everything from like on the go whenever I have a, you know, like some money gets auto deposited and I want to invest it in a, you know, indexed ETF or whatever. I just handle it, you know,
我除了创建账户外，不会去网站。我像是在旅途中管理一切，每当有钱自动存入，我想把它投资到指数 ETF 或其他什么东西时，我就处理它，你知道，
wherever I am. And I just think it's kind of crazy to think that would have been me phoning some guy sitting behind a desk to execute an order. Not even what, like five years ago. And now I just do it from like a tablet or my mobile phone. The trade prices are reasonable. And there's ways to get even better deals than what they have posted.
无论我在哪里。想到如果是在五年前，我可能还得打电话给坐在办公桌后的某个人来执行订单，这真是太疯狂了。而现在我只需要用平板电脑或手机就能完成。交易价格很合理。而且有办法获得比他们公布的更好的交易条件。
Not me endorsing TD Ameritrade, but just saying. So what are the fees? It slips my mind now. I think it's $5 for a stock trade. Oh, that's better than E-Trade. E-Trade's $10. So I have like a special, like I said i said if you shop around there's like other ways like referral links basically where gotcha you have to refer me hook me up so so yeah so like
不是我在为 TD Ameritrade 背书，只是说说而已。那么费用是多少？我现在想不起来了。我想每笔股票交易是 5 美元。哦，那比 E-Trade 好。E-Trade 是 10 美元。所以我有一个特别的……就像我说的，如果你货比三家，还有其他方式，比如推荐链接，基本上就是……我明白了，你得推荐我，帮我一把。所以，是的，就像
i'm not specifically like far be it from me to uh give investment advice although i'll tell you my opinions oh no we will never we will uh yeah let's not get in there yeah yeah so but um i'm just saying like for me it's just about that this specific one think of someone i really like the way it's designed and the way it operates and uh also i think it's just crazy that we can do this now that like i don't have to even be on my laptop or yet much less the phone which i hate uh calling people um and so instead instead this is amazing like you can just oh you can just like take your phone out of your pocket and say oh look i think this looks pretty interesting yeah i'm sitting here like you know waiting for a doctor's appointment or
我并不是特别……我绝不会提供投资建议，尽管我会告诉你我的观点。哦，不，我们永远不会……是的，我们别谈那个。是的，是的。但……我只是说，对我来说，这只是关于这个特定的 ThinkOrSwim，我真的很喜欢它的设计和操作方式。而且我也觉得我们现在能做到这一点真是太疯狂了，我甚至不需要在笔记本电脑上，更不用说手机了，我讨厌打电话给别人。所以相反，这太神奇了，你可以直接从口袋里掏出手机说：“哦，看，我觉得这个看起来很有趣。”是的，我坐在这里，你知道，等着看医生或者
something and you just have some time to uh study your financial situation yeah and it really takes away like the like procrastination ability because it's like oh well this weekend i'll get on and i'll oh but the market's closed i'll wait till i'll set up or you know whatever blah blah you just do it uh so it's seven dollars is my rate for flat stock oh okay yeah you'll have to add me under do it okay all right all right i like how they're uh they're one of their bullet points here is they add zing to my ding ding. Oh, I think that's because it's the noise it makes when you execute a trade. Oh, okay. Okay.
什么的，你就有时间去研究你的财务状况了。它确实消除了拖延的可能性，因为你会想：“哦，好吧，这个周末我会上去看看。”但市场关门了，我会等到……或者你知道，随便吧，你直接就做了。所以我的股票交易费率是 7 美元。哦，好吧。是的，你得把我加进去。好的，好的。我喜欢他们的一点是，他们的一条要点是“为我的叮叮声增加活力”（add zing to my ding ding）。哦，我想那是因为那是你执行交易时发出的声音。哦，好吧。好的。
Well, I mean, who doesn't want that? Yeah. Anyway, so the only thing you got to be careful with all these things is there's a incentive to try to make you trade more and i'm a firm believer that i think trading more just gets you into more trouble oh yeah i don't yeah yeah can you do like uh can you schedule things in advance so you can set like a good to cancel order so yeah so like a good to cancel limit order like i want to buy tesla at this amount or this etf at this amount and i want it to be good until i cancel it well can you do like like say i want to buy tesla you know the
好吧，我的意思是，谁不想要那个呢？是的。总之，关于所有这些事情，你唯一需要小心的是，有一种激励机制试图让你交易更多。我坚信交易更多只会让你陷入更多麻烦。哦，是的，我不同意。是的，是的。你能提前安排事情吗？所以你可以设置像“有效直到取消”（good to cancel）的订单。所以，是的，比如“有效直到取消”的限价单，比如我想以这个价格买入特斯拉，或者以这个价格买入这个 ETF，并且我希望它一直有效直到我取消它。好吧，你能做类似……比如我想买特斯拉，你知道，
15th of every month oh i don't know kind of stuff i've i haven't tried doing that it's possible there's a lot of really like crazy stuff in the program so okay uh so yeah more not an endorsement to to trade or not you heard it from us by tesla don't you don't do that but the amazing moving of also the other one a lot of people use what is that called uh oh why is the name skip interactive brokers interactive brokers is another one people recommend a lot that's i guess relatively low cost um and and they also have a mobile one that i've used and i was gonna, Thinkorswim also, even if you don't open an account,
每个月的 15 号。哦，我不知道那种事情。我还没试过。这可能是有可能的，程序里有很多非常疯狂的东西。所以，好的。所以，是的，更多不是鼓励交易或不交易。你从我们这里听到的，买特斯拉，别……别那样做。但令人惊叹的移动端，还有很多人使用的另一个，那叫什么来着？哦，为什么名字想不起来了？盈透证券（Interactive Brokers）。盈透证券是另一个人们推荐很多的平台，我想它的成本相对较低。而且他们也有一个我用过的移动端。我本来想说，ThinkOrSwim 也是，即使你不开户，
they have like the paper trading one. And if you're just into like stock trade, like checking stock charts and stock prices, I think it's 20 minute delayed if you don't have an account. But for most people, that shouldn't be a big problem. I don't, anyways. And so that just even using it to check stock prices
他们也有模拟交易功能。如果你只是喜欢查看股票图表和股票价格，我想如果你没有账户，会有 20 分钟的延迟。但对于大多数人来说，这应该不是什么大问题。我不知道，总之。所以即使只是用它来查看股票价格
and stuff, I find it to be a useful application. Cool. So it works on the phone or the iPad or both or i don't know if it's on android but for sure i have it on my iphone and my ipad and they're both beautiful and nice and i like them very cool so that was way too many caveats for a tool of the show moving on time for node.js. Node.js. So, yeah, so Node.js is pretty cool. So we talked about Node.js very briefly when we covered JavaScript a long time ago. I don't remember what episode that was. But at the time, you know, to confess, neither of us had ever, you know, written any, you know, big projects or anything like that in Node.
之类的，我觉得它是一个有用的应用程序。酷。所以它可以在手机或 iPad 上运行，还是两者都可以？我不知道它是否在安卓上有，但我确定我的 iPhone 和 iPad 上都有，它们都很漂亮，很好用，我喜欢它们。非常酷。所以对于一个节目工具来说，这太多的注意事项了。继续，Node.js 时间。Node.js。所以，是的，Node.js 很酷。我们在很久以前介绍 JavaScript 时简要谈过 Node.js。我不记得那是哪一集了。但在当时，坦白说，我们俩都从未写过任何大型项目之类的 Node 程序。
And since then, Node has come a long way. We've come a long way in terms of what we code day to day. And so we have a lot more to say about Node.js. It's pretty cool. The basic premise of Node.js is that JavaScript is the language of the browser. So if you want to do something interactive on the browser, you're almost certainly going to have to write it in JavaScript. And Node.js is a JavaScript-based engine for desktops.
从那时起，Node 已经取得了长足的进步。我们在日常编码方面也取得了长足的进步。所以我们对 Node.js 有更多的话要说。它很酷。Node.js 的基本前提是 JavaScript 是浏览器的语言。所以如果你想在浏览器上做一些交互式的事情，你几乎肯定必须用 JavaScript 编写它。而 Node.js 是一个基于 JavaScript 的桌面引擎。
And so it's kind of nice because you can stay to just one language. And we'll talk about that more later why that's convenient. Yeah, so to give the one-line summary, because sometimes it's frustrating to figure out what something really does, this is basically to allow you to run JavaScript not in your browser. That's right. Think of it as like a command
所以这很好，因为你可以只用一种语言。我们稍后会详细讨论为什么这很方便。是的，给出一个一句话的总结，因为有时弄清楚某样东西到底是做什么的会很令人沮丧，这基本上是为了让你在浏览器之外运行 JavaScript。没错。把它想象成一个命令行
line JavaScript engine, right? Yes. It took me a while to actually figure out what it was supposed to be nice not not for this episode but when i first heard about it yeah right right um do you want to cover some of the history sure so uh in node.js like we said is a javascript uh engine to run on a pc outside of a browser and uh the thing that led to its development was that in 2008 uh google released the v8 javascript engine which is what they use for executing javascript inside of google chrome but they released it as a standalone so you could kind of compile
JavaScript 引擎，对吧？是的。我花了一段时间才真正弄清楚它应该是做什么的。不错，不是为了这一集，而是当我第一次听说它的时候。是的，没错。嗯，你想介绍一下历史吗？当然。所以，Node.js 就像我们说的，是一个在浏览器之外的 PC 上运行的 JavaScript 引擎。导致它发展的原因是，2008 年谷歌发布了 V8 JavaScript 引擎，这是他们在谷歌浏览器内部执行 JavaScript 所使用的引擎，但他们将其作为独立版本发布，所以你可以编译
javascript and run it and in 2009 um ryan doll workingent, which is a cloud services company. And so he released this thing called Node.js onto the scene, which was essentially kind of like a framework, encapsulation of VA inside of it in a platform to allow you to even more easily run, essentially, JavaScript programs as if they were almost native executables, as it were. Yeah, like what Node.js does is it connects job because you know like javascript ran on the command line with the v8 but it didn't have access to the os like someone had to go in and write the read a file function or the send a byte over the network you know well actually i guess that one's in javascript but like like the read a file function or the send a byte over the network, you know, well, actually, I guess that one's in JavaScript, but like the read a file function
JavaScript 并运行它。2009 年，瑞安·达尔（Ryan Dahl）在一家云服务公司工作。于是他发布了这个名为 Node.js 的东西，它本质上就像一个框架，将 V8 封装在其中，作为一个平台，让你更容易地运行 JavaScript 程序，就像它们几乎是原生可执行文件一样。是的，Node.js 所做的是它连接了……因为你知道 JavaScript 在命令行上运行 V8，但它没有访问操作系统的权限。有人必须进去编写“读取文件”函数或“通过网络发送字节”函数，你知道，好吧，其实我猜那个是在 JavaScript 里的，但像“读取文件”函数或“通过网络发送字节”函数，你知道，好吧，其实我猜那个是在 JavaScript 里的，但像“读取文件”函数
or the control your mouse function or the read from the keyboard function, like these low level, you know, C operating system functions, someone had to connect them to the JavaScript engine. And that's what Ryan Dahl did with Node. Yeah, so some of the pros so one pretty cool thing about this is it's it's all JavaScript which is pretty cool JavaScript is weakly typed if you remember from the episode so what that
或“控制鼠标”函数或“从键盘读取”函数，这些底层的 C 操作系统函数，有人必须将它们连接到 JavaScript 引擎。这就是瑞安·达尔用 Node 所做的事情。是的，所以一些优点，其中一个很酷的事情是它全是 JavaScript，这很酷。JavaScript 是弱类型的，如果你还记得那一集的话。所以这意味着
means is the advantage of that is basically in JavaScript, everything is either a dictionary or an array or a primitive, like a string or a number. So everything's a bunch of dictionaries and arrays. You have dictionaries of arrays, so on and so forth. And then that maps very well to JSON, which is not a coincidence. It's called JavaScript Object Notation. And so JSON is a, you can think of it as like a serialized form of a JavaScript object. So you can take some JavaScript object, maybe it's a dictionary, and it has a key called user, and the value is someone's name, and it has a key called friends, and the value is some list of friends' names.
它的优势基本上在于 JavaScript 中，一切要么是字典，要么是数组，要么是原始类型，比如字符串或数字。所以一切都是一堆字典和数组。你有字典的数组，以此类推。然后这与 JSON 映射得非常好，这并非巧合。它被称为 JavaScript 对象表示法（JavaScript Object Notation）。所以 JSON 是一个……你可以把它看作是 JavaScript 对象的一种序列化形式。所以你可以拿一个 JavaScript 对象，也许它是一个字典，它有一个键叫“用户”，值是某人的名字，它有一个键叫“朋友”，值是朋友名字的列表。
And you can have this JavaScript object and say user.name, printuser.name, printuser.friends. And then you can say, hey, take this object and turn it into a JSON string now once it's a string you can you know send it across the network you can serialize it to disk you do whatever you want and then at any point you can say JSON dot parse and it turns your string back into a JavaScript object where you can like run functions on it and stuff like that. So this is pretty cool, right? Cause you see how this is going. Like you could be on the browser writing
你可以拥有这个 JavaScript 对象并说 user.name，打印 user.name，打印 user.friends。然后你可以说，嘿，把这个对象变成一个 JSON 字符串。现在一旦它是一个字符串，你就可以在网络上传输它，你可以把它序列化到磁盘，做任何你想做的事。然后在任何时候，你可以说 JSON.parse，它会把你的字符串变回一个 JavaScript 对象，你可以在上面运行函数之类的。所以这很酷，对吧？因为你看到了这是怎么回事。就像你可以在浏览器上编写
what's your JavaScript and you can say, hey, take these objects and turn them into strings. Then send them to the server. The server's running node JS. It says, hey, take these strings, turn them back into objects and then just start accessing. I'm just like like you know keep resume where i left off um um doing the server side um this is especially useful for validation right
你的 JavaScript，你可以说，嘿，把这些对象变成字符串。然后把它们发送到服务器。服务器运行着 Node.js。它说，嘿，把这些字符串变回对象，然后就开始访问。我只是……就像你知道，从我离开的地方继续……做服务器端。这对于验证特别有用，对吧？
so right now a lot of people don't know this but if you go in your browser and like you try to log into your bank or something and you don't put a password you just hit enter or you put the wrong password like your bank like or if you put a if you put no password it won't even let you log in like before you even go to click the login button like the password box will turn red or maybe like right when you click immediately it'll turn red and your browser will just tell you look dude you didn't put a password this isn't gonna to work right um and so or you know if you if you try to sign up on a website and it says put in your email address and you put a and you hit enter or even before you
所以现在很多人不知道这一点，但如果你进入浏览器，试图登录你的银行之类的，你没有输入密码，你只是按了回车，或者你输入了错误的密码，比如你的银行……或者如果你输入了没有密码，它甚至不会让你登录。在你点击登录按钮之前，密码框会变红，或者可能就在你点击时，它会立即变红，你的浏览器会直接告诉你：“伙计，你没输入密码，这行不通。”对吧？或者你知道，如果你试图在一个网站上注册，它说输入你的电子邮件地址，你输入了一个“a”并按了回车，甚至在你
hit enter it might say look that's not a is not an email address it's not going to work right but that validation that's happening on the browser, it's impossible to enforce. I could always go in and hack the JavaScript on any website I want on the browser side to let me make my email B and A. But that's why you have to duplicate it. So on the browser, on the client side, you check just to keep things easy and keep the flow going and make it convenient. But then when you hit the server, you have to check again to make sure that someone isn't trying to be malicious or have a broken browser or something. And so if you're going to be checking twice, it'd be pretty cool if you could reuse the
按回车之前，它可能会说：“看，那不是电子邮件地址，这行不通。”对吧？但那种在浏览器上发生的验证，是不可能强制执行的。我总是可以进去黑掉任何我想要的网站上的 JavaScript，在浏览器端让我把我的电子邮件变成“a”。但这就是为什么你必须重复它。所以，在浏览器上，在客户端，你检查只是为了让事情变得简单，保持流程顺畅，让它方便。但当你到达服务器时，你必须再次检查，以确保没有人试图恶意操作或浏览器损坏之类的。所以如果你要检查两次，如果你能重用
same code that does the checking. And so Node.js gives you that. So you write the validation code in JavaScript once, and then you can use it on the client and on the server. And you know it's going to work exactly the same. Like, you're not going to type some email address that the browser thinks is okay, but then the server doesn't think is okay. So, yes, especially for validation, but also for other reasons, Node.js is pretty awesome, especially for a front-end. It also has some great MVC frameworks.
做检查的同一段代码，那会很酷。所以 Node.js 给了你这个。所以你用 JavaScript 编写一次验证代码，然后你就可以在客户端和服务器上使用它。而且你知道它会完全一样地工作。你不会输入一些浏览器认为可以，但服务器认为不可以的电子邮件地址。所以，是的，特别是对于验证，但也因为其他原因，Node.js 非常棒，特别是对于前端。它还有一些很棒的 MVC 框架。
That's Model View Controller frameworks. I personally prefer Express. I think Express is pretty awesome. There's also a bunch of other ones. But basically what these do is they just make your life easier. If you want to get a website up and running quickly, you need things like templating, you need to compile your CSS,
也就是模型-视图-控制器（Model View Controller）框架。我个人更喜欢 Express。我觉得 Express 非常棒。还有很多其他的。但基本上这些所做的是它们让你的生活更轻松。如果你想快速建立并运行一个网站，你需要模板引擎，你需要编译 CSS，
you need to have a model, right? So you need to connect it to a database and express, you know, handle login authentication. Express does all of these things for you and it just makes it super easy. Another pro is that um all the blocking calls in node.js aren't really that would normally be blocking aren't really allowed to block they are handled with a callback and so this keeps your code um able to scale a little bit better
你需要一个模型，对吧？所以你需要把它连接到数据库，而 Express 处理登录认证。Express 为你处理所有这些事情，它让一切变得超级简单。另一个优点是，Node.js 中所有通常会阻塞的调用实际上并不被允许阻塞，它们是用回调处理的，所以这让你的代码能够更好地扩展。
um so normally you know what the way we work is like if you have a server and a request comes in to initiate a connection, you would spawn a thread to service that connection during the life of that connection. But this is fraught with all sorts of resource problems in the number of simultaneous requests you can handle. Versus in Node,
通常你知道，我们的工作方式是，如果你有一个服务器，一个请求进来发起连接，你会生成一个线程来在连接期间为该连接服务。但这充满了各种资源问题，关于你能处理的并发请求数量。而在 Node 中，
Node.js, the concept is that when that request comes in and you do some work and then you're waiting, for instance, for.js, the concept is that when that request comes in and you do some work and then you're waiting, for instance, for a response, instead of having a thread there, it goes and does something else. And when the server itself, the Node.js framework understands that the response has come in, it'll kind of call the callback you registered and then stuff can progress. And that way it can juggle a lot more simultaneous things happening at once. Mm-hmm. Yep.
Node.js 的概念是，当那个请求进来时，你做了一些工作，然后你在等待，例如，响应，而不是在那里占用一个线程，它会去处理别的事情。当服务器本身，Node.js 框架理解响应已经到来时，它会调用你注册的回调，然后事情就可以继续进行。这样它就可以同时处理更多的事情。嗯哼。是的。
So, yeah, some of the cons, it's weakly typed. So you could push bad code, right? I mean, unless you're doing your own sort of type checking with some kind of other library, like unless you're using TypeScript or something like that, which we talked about in another episode. Some people would say this is a pro really i i mean this is a javascript thing right like a lot of people i don't say they really like it but i mean there's always this thing that yeah i don't know yeah so to pat right, the whole, like, being able to go from the JSON string to the object and back only exists because it's weakly typed,
所以，是的，一些缺点，它是弱类型的。所以你可能会推送糟糕的代码，对吧？我的意思是，除非你用某种其他库进行自己的类型检查，比如除非你使用 TypeScript 之类的，我们在另一集里谈过。有些人会说这其实是一个优点，我的意思是，这是一个 JavaScript 的特性，对吧？就像很多人，我不是说他们真的很喜欢它，但我的意思是，总是有这种……我不知道。是的，所以对于 Pat 来说，从 JSON 字符串到对象再变回来的整个过程，只有在它是弱类型的情况下才存在，
and we called that a pro. So, like, one of the pros that we even mentioned wouldn't have been possible if it wasn't for this con, right? But at the end of the day, like, you can get burned by this, right? So it's like anything there's no there's no silver bullet uh we wouldn't be on our 41th 41st episode 41 that's our second mistake ever we wouldn't be on our 41st episode if uh if if there was just one language as a silver bullet right but i mean it's free for something it's fine for something to be a pro and a con but yeah yeah right but being legally typed i've definitely
而我们称之为优点。所以，我们提到的优点之一，如果不是因为这个缺点，是不可能实现的，对吧？但归根结底，你可能会因此被烧伤，对吧？所以就像任何事情一样，没有银弹。如果我们有一种语言是银弹，我们就不会在第 41 集了。41，这是我们有史以来第二次错误。如果我们有一种语言是银弹，我们就不会在第 41 集了，对吧？但我的意思是，一件事情既是优点又是缺点是可以的。但是的，是的，没错。但作为弱类型，我绝对
gotten burned by it um and one other thing about node.js in particular and i don't know why i think actually you can configure it to be differently to be different but by default if if any of your web service requests crash, the entire server crashes and is just gone. So in other words, if you have what's called a query of death, which means there is some particular use case that can cause your server to crash. Like for example, let's say you divide by the number of characters that someone put in an input box and someone puts it empty and you don't check for empty. And so when they hit submit, if they didn't fill in a box under those conditions, you divide by zero and bomb out, right? In Node.js, if you do that, like if you have a million people hitting your website and one person does that, it kills the website for everybody. So it's kind of got this thing where it's weekly typed,
被它烧伤过。而且关于 Node.js 特别是还有一件事，我不知道为什么，我想其实你可以配置它以不同的方式，但默认情况下，如果你的任何 Web 服务请求崩溃，整个服务器都会崩溃并直接消失。换句话说，如果你有所谓的“死亡查询”（query of death），这意味着有一些特定的用例会导致你的服务器崩溃。比如，假设你除以某人在输入框中输入的字符数，而有人输入了空值，而你没有检查空值。所以当他们点击提交时，如果他们在那种情况下没有填框，你就会除以零并炸掉，对吧？在 Node.js 中，如果你这样做，比如有一百万人访问你的网站，而一个人这样做了，它会杀死所有人的网站。所以它有这种弱类型的特性，
it's easy to get kind of runtime errors, and when you do, they're totally catastrophic. I do think there are ways to fix it, such that if it bombs out, it's only for that session session that's kind of like how Java and some of these other servers work but by default it doesn't do that and so that's one thing to be aware of so we also said that a pro was the asynchronous nature and how that sometimes can help performance but now we're gonna have two cons in a row that talk about some of the possible problems with it and the first is that uh you can end up with just crazy amounts of callbacks nested
很容易出现运行时错误，而且当你出现错误时，它们是完全灾难性的。我确实认为有办法修复它，这样如果它炸掉，只会影响那个会话，这有点像 Java 和其他一些服务器的工作方式，但默认情况下它不会那样做，所以这是需要注意的一点。所以我们也说过一个优点是异步特性以及它有时如何帮助性能，但现在我们要连续说两个缺点，谈谈它可能存在的一些问题。第一个是，你最终可能会得到疯狂数量的回调嵌套
inside of each other because every time you want to try to do something that would be blocking you need to come up with a callback and unless you're disciplined as a programmer you can end up with just code that is a nightmare to read and follow and trace and see where problems are occurring. And you have to be really diligent to avoid that. Yeah, and I mean, in some languages, like Java, for example, like most things are synchronous, but then you can do things asynchronously. Like in Java, for example, you could have a class that implements runnable, and you could just call
在彼此内部，因为每次你想尝试做一些会阻塞的事情时，你都需要想出一个回调，除非你作为一个程序员很有纪律，否则你最终可能会得到一段阅读、跟踪和查看问题发生位置的噩梦般的代码。你必须非常勤奋才能避免这种情况。是的，我的意思是，在某些语言中，比如 Java，大多数事情是同步的，但你可以异步地做事情。比如在 Java 中，你可以有一个实现 Runnable 的类，你可以直接调用
the dot run function and synchronously run that class or you could spin off a thread or assign it to a thread pool and then it'll run asynchronously right but here it's fixed so that's why like if you look at the node.js api there's read file read synchronous, you know, there's a bunch of these, like for almost any function, there's a synchronous version of it. And that's because there's no way in the language for you to handle both cases without duplicating all of your code. And so what ends up happening is most people just write the asynchronous version of everything. and then you end up with just every single function has a callback and it gets pretty ugly yeah cuz you know most of the time you can be really thin and so it ends up being oh man why is the name escaping me anonymous callback which is also very difficult so it's
run 函数并同步运行该类，或者你可以生成一个线程或将其分配给线程池，然后它会异步运行，对吧？但在这里它是固定的，所以这就是为什么如果你看 Node.js API，有 read file，read synchronous，你知道，几乎对于任何函数，都有一个同步版本。这是因为在语言中没有办法让你在不重复所有代码的情况下处理这两种情况。所以最终发生的是，大多数人只是编写所有东西的异步版本。然后你最终得到每个函数都有一个回调，这变得相当丑陋。是的，因为你知道大多数时候你可以非常精简，所以最终变成了……哦，天哪，为什么名字想不起来了？匿名回调，这也非常困难。所以它
just kind of like right there in line yeah right right um another con is performance um it's so it's interpreted you know as you guys know interpreted languages are naturally kind of slower so you're not going to use this for doing some heavy image processing and things like that um it does have a lot of great support for libraries, like ImageMagick and things like that. It has a lot of C and C++ libraries that it wraps that you'd use for something like that. But by default, you're not going to do anything that does any signal processing or anything like that in Node. It's also single-threaded, which is kind of wild, right?
只是像那样内联。是的，没错。另一个缺点是性能。它是解释型的，你知道，正如你们所知，解释型语言自然比较慢，所以你不会用它来做一些繁重的图像处理之类的东西。它确实对库有很好的支持，比如 ImageMagick 之类的。它有很多它封装的 C 和 C++ 库，你可以用于类似的事情。但默认情况下，你不会在 Node 中做任何进行信号处理之类的东西。它也是单线程的，这有点疯狂，对吧？
You'd build a server where it only runs on one thread. But as Patrick said, because of its asynchronous nature, it's just that one thread is busy all the time. Whereas in other languages, that thread might be just blocked on disk IO or it's blocked on waiting for a network packet or something like that. But in Node, everything is so asynchronous
你会构建一个服务器，它只在一个线程上运行。但正如 Patrick 所说，因为它的异步特性，只是那个线程一直很忙。而在其他语言中，那个线程可能只是阻塞在磁盘 IO 上，或者阻塞在等待网络数据包之类的。但在 Node 中，一切都是如此异步，
that that thread is always doing something useful. Like if you're reading from a file, then there's some callback that gets fired when it's done. And in the meantime, something else is happening. So yeah, that's Node.js. I'm a big fan. I think it's awesome. I think if you want to get a website up and running quickly this is the way to do it but it has a
以至于那个线程总是在做一些有用的事情。比如如果你正在从文件中读取，那么当它完成时会触发一些回调。在此期间，其他事情正在发生。所以是的，这就是 Node.js。我是它的忠实粉丝。我觉得它很棒。我觉得如果你想快速建立并运行一个网站，这是最好的方法，但它也有
lot of great frameworks and things like that too for building professional professional stuff so I do think if you want to do something more sophisticated like write some kind of game server or something you could still use this but then this node.js would be kind of your front end it's like you'd have your browser you'd have node.js that talks directly to the browser and then it would write information to a database then you'd have some other program in java or something that's you know maybe pulling that database and then doing the more like heavy duty work right like i don't think you would want to write some
很多很棒的框架之类的，用于构建专业的东西。所以我确实认为如果你想做一些更复杂的事情，比如编写某种游戏服务器之类的，你仍然可以使用它，但那时 Node.js 会是你的前端。就像你会拥有浏览器，你会拥有直接与浏览器对话的 Node.js，然后它会将信息写入数据库，然后你会有一些其他用 Java 或其他语言编写的程序，可能在轮询该数据库，然后做更繁重的工作。对吧？我的意思是，我不认为你会想在里面编写一些
very complicated um you know project in this so this is mainly meant to be pretty lightweight so although i think people do write complicated things like uh uber i believe uh writes their view that shows like where all the uber cabs are in a given city they track out using node.js oh yeah that makes sense so for things like if it's complicated in the sense like it's a lot of data and things like that node.js works well but like for example like the routing like routing the cars i'm pretty sure that uber has something in c++ i just remember hearing anecdotally one time talking about like large users of node.js yeah right you can definitely scale node.js very well so i did talk about the single threaded but of course you can have multiple processes right so you have, instead of one Node.js server per machine,
非常复杂的项目。所以这主要是为了相当轻量级。虽然我认为人们确实编写了复杂的东西，比如 Uber，我相信他们编写了显示所有 Uber 出租车在给定城市位置的视图，他们使用 Node.js 进行跟踪。哦，是的，这说得通。所以对于像数据量很大之类的事情，Node.js 工作得很好。但例如，像路由，规划汽车路线，我敢肯定 Uber 有一些 C++ 的东西。我只是记得有一次听到关于 Node.js 大用户的轶事。是的，没错，你绝对可以很好地扩展 Node.js。所以我确实谈到了单线程，但当然你可以有多个进程，对吧？所以你有，而不是每台机器一个 Node.js 服务器，
you could have 1,000 per machine, or you could have the number of threads times two per machine, and then you're maxing out, you know, that machine just as you would with a single Java server, right? So, yeah, you could definitely scale it up, but with the weakly typed and other things, you know, you definitely wouldn scale it up. But with the weekly typed and other things, you definitely wouldn't want to do machine learning or something like that in Node.js.
你可以每台机器有 1000 个，或者你可以每台机器有线程数乘以 2，然后你就可以像使用单个 Java 服务器一样最大限度地利用那台机器，对吧？所以，是的，你绝对可以扩展它，但由于弱类型和其他事情，你知道，你绝对不会……由于弱类型和其他事情，你绝对不会想在 Node.js 中进行机器学习之类的。
It would kind of be a nightmare. All right, well, I think that's a wrap for Node.js. Yeah, check it out. It's really awesome. A lot of people say, how do I get started in programming? And there's basically two pieces of two paths you can go like one assembly brutal one is like most people want either make a game in which case you could get started with you know all the things we talked about on the game engines
那会是一场噩梦。好吧，我想 Node.js 就到这里了。是的，去看看吧。它真的很棒。很多人问，我该如何开始编程？基本上有两条路你可以走，一条是残酷的汇编，一条是大多数人想要的，要么做一个游戏，在这种情况下，你可以从我们谈论过的所有游戏引擎开始
episode or make a website and if you're of the latter kind and you want to make a website i definitely recommend using this it's pretty slick html blink tags for the um oh god yeah and yeah everything should be blinking everything everything the entire document always always um so yeah this is pretty cool so well a couple things to mention one uh in the past like four or five months, the bandwidth has doubled, which is pretty awesome. It means that there's a lot of people following the podcast. Oh, that's why we're concerned about net neutrality.
那一集，或者做一个网站。如果你是后者，并且你想做一个网站，我绝对推荐使用这个，它非常简洁。HTML blink 标签用于……哦，天哪，是的，一切都应该闪烁，一切，整个文档，总是，总是。所以是的，这很酷。所以，嗯，有几件事要提。一，在过去四五个月里，带宽翻了一番，这非常棒。这意味着有很多听众在关注这个播客。哦，这就是为什么我们担心网络中立性。
Yeah, that's right. We're the beneficiary of net neutrality. Yeah, we're using, I don't remember what the number is, like three terabytes or something, like two and a half terabytes. We're using like a ton of bandwidth per month, but it's great because it's a service that a lot of people are taking advantage of. And so we appreciate you guys. So there are a lot of new listeners out there, but they may be listening to old episodes. But if you're listening to the new episodes, welcome.
是的，没错。我们是网络中立的受益者。我们每个月使用的带宽非常大，我不记得具体数字了，大概是三太字节或者两点五太字节左右。但这很棒，因为这是一项很多人都在使用的服务。所以我们很感谢大家。有很多新听众，他们可能正在听旧的剧集。但如果你正在听最新的剧集，欢迎你们。
That's right. And you made it all the way through your first one. By the time you hear this, you're already a veteran and it's wasted. It's sort of like a paradox. But if you are listening to the first time and you get to this episode or you're going backwards or something, we have the Facebook page for Programming Throwdown. We have the Google Plus page.
没错。而且你已经完整听完了你的第一集。当你听到这里时，你已经是老手了，这感觉有点浪费。这就像是一个悖论。但如果你是第一次收听，并且听到了这一集，或者你是倒着听之类的，我们有Programming Throwdown的Facebook页面，还有Google Plus页面。
Sorry, the Google Plus community. We're on Twitter. We have the Neural Nets for Life Twitter handle. And so, you know, stay in touch with us, communicate with us. We definitely, if we get some user mail, someone asked me about unit tests. So my tool of the show, not coincidentally, was a unit test tool. So if you have any feedback or anything like that, anything you want to ask, don't hesitate to ping us on those forums or send us an email. That was very well said. You've done this 41 times.
抱歉，是Google Plus社区。我们在Twitter上也有账号。我们有Neural Nets for Life的Twitter账号。所以，请和我们保持联系，与我们交流。如果收到听众来信，我们一定会回复。有人问过我关于单元测试的问题，所以本期节目的工具推荐，巧合的是，正是一个单元测试工具。如果你有任何反馈或想问的问题，请随时在这些论坛上联系我们或给我们发电子邮件。说得太好了。你已经做过41次了。
You're a pro. All right, until next time. Cool. See're a pro. All right. Till next time. Cool. See you guys later. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work.
你已经是专业人士了。好了，下次见。酷。回头见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown采用知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，也可以进行重混和改编。
But you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。